Traditionally design documentation has included information about the components
you've carved the system up into, what their responsibilities are,
what their primary data flows are and so on. Other elements of traditional
documentation include, how you going to deal with performance considerations.
And resource consumption, by resource here we might mean memory,
we might mean use of peripherals, bandwidth and so on. It that's not enough for
you, if your organization needs more detail documentation,
you might rely on some IEEE standards, such as standard 1016.
Some of the key elements that the standard add to the list
that is traditionally used are things like who is the designer? It might be
nice to know if you have to go back for a question, who was responsible for
a particular piece of the design. What are the dependencies among the elements?
Are there hidden assumptions that one component is making about other
components? What are the tradeoffs among the non-functional constraints?
How did you decide to take a particular tradeoff? What assumptions are you
making about your users, about the technology that will be available for
the hardware, and about the changing customer base? And
which particular. Views of the software system as your documentation providing.